MOTHERHOOD IS A GOOD IDEA FOR
SOCIETY.
IT'S NOT.
IT'S A TRAGEDY ESPECIALLY FOR
BOYS AND THE REST OF US SHOULD
STOP LYING ABOUT THAT.
DR. WARREN FARRELL LOOKED INTO
THIS SUBJECT CLOSELY AND
AUTHORED "THE BOY CRISIS."
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
WE KNOW PRETTY CONCLUSIVELY
THAT MEN IN AMERICA AND OTHER
DEVELOPED COUNTRIES ARE
FALLING BEHIND WOMEN IN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT MEASURES.
TO WHAT EXTENT IS
FATHERLESSNESS DRIVING THAT,
DO YOU THINK?
>> A GREAT EXTENT.
THEY ARE FALLING BEHIND WOMEN
IN ALL 63 LEADING NATIONS,
DEVELOPED NATIONS.
AND IN DEVELOPED NATIONS THERE
IS THE PERMISSION FOR DIVORCE
THAT THERE ISN'T IN THE
NON-DEVELOPED, THE LESS
DEVELOPED NATIONS.
ALSO IN DEVELOPED NATION IS
THE PERMISSION FOR WOMEN TO
MARRY, TO HAVE CHILDREN
WITHOUT BEING MARRIED.
THAT CREATES A DIVISION
BETWEEN BOYS WHO ARE WITH THE
FATHERS DOING QUITE WELL, BOYS
WHO ARE NOT WITH THEIR FATHERS
DO TERRIBLY ON MORE THAN 70
DIFFERENT MEASURES.
LIKE POSTPONED GRATIFICATION.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY ARE
DEPRESSED OR DRINKING.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE
DRUGS.
THE OPIOID CRISIS.
PEOPLE INVOLVED WITH THE ISIS
RECRUIT ALL OVER THE WORLD ARE
ALMOST COMPLETELY FATHERLESS
BOYS.
THE ONES THAT ARE GIRLS ARE
ALSO FATHERLESS.
SO EVERYTHING YOU HAVE BEEN
SAYING FOR THE SERIES IS ON
TARGET WITH THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING CHILDREN BE INVOLVED
WITH BOTH FATHERS.
MOTHERS ARE DOING A HUGE
AMOUNT OF WONDERFUL, HARD
WORK, LOVING AND CARING FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> THAT IS WHY THEY DESERVE
THE BIOLOGICAL FATHER TO BE
INVOLVED.
AND WHEN WE TELL THE
BIOLOGICAL FATHER NOT ONLY ARE
YOU IMPORTANT BUT THE WAY THAT
YOU FATHER IS IMPORTANT, THE
WAY THAT YOU ENFORCE
BOUNDARIES AND THE WAY YOU
ENCOURAGE EXPLORATION AND
ENCOURAGE THE KIDS TO GET UP
AND TRY AGAIN.
THE WAY YOU ENCOURAGE
ADVENTURE AND RISK-TAKING.
THE WAY THAT WE CAN PLAY
TOGETHER TO CREATE BONDS,
THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT
MOTHERS NEED TO COMMUNICATE.
BECAUSE WHEN FATHERS ARE ASKED
FOR AND VALUED THEY COME BACK
IN THE PICTURE.
WHEN THEY ARE NOT, THEY DROP
OUT.
>> Tucker: SO IT DOESN'T
SOUND LIKE ANYBODY WINS FROM
FATHERLESSNESS.
SO THE TREND IS FEWER FAMILIES
ARE FORMING MORE CHILDREN
GROWING UP WITHOUT THE FATHERS
AT HOME.
NOBODY BENEFITS FROM THAT.
WHY AREN'T WE SOUNDING THE
ALARM ABOUT THAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WE PUT SO MUCH FOCUS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ON FREEDOM FOR WOMEN.
AND FREEDOM FOR WOMEN IS A
WONDERFUL THING.
I WAS ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS FOR THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION OF WOMEN IN NEW
YORK CITY FOR MANY YEARS, AS
YOU KNOW.
BUT FREEDOM FOR WOMEN STOPS
WHEN THEY MAKE THE FREE CHOICE
TO HAVE CHILDREN.
AND THEN A DIFFERENT QUESTION
HAS TO EMERGE WHICH IS WHAT IS
BEST FOR THE CHILDREN?
WE SEE EVIDENCE OF BEYOND WHAT
I THOUGHT DOING RESEARCH FOR
"BOY CRISIS."
CHILDREN DO BEST WHEN THERE IS
NOT JUST A FATHER, BUT THE
BIOLOGICAL FATHER AND THE
BIOLOGICAL FATHER IS FAR LESS
LIKELY TO DROP OUT OF THE
PROCESS WHEN THERE IS
MARRIAGE.
40% OF EVEN MEN AND WOMEN WHO
LIVE TOGETHER WHO DON'T GET